with a runtime clocking in over three
hours it might be easier to explain what
doesn't happen in Avengers endgame
instead of what does for instance fans
don't get bored fans don't get up to use
the bathroom and fans don't ever want it
to end but it didn't and we're here to
explain what that ending was all about
here's the ending of Avengers endgame
explained with lots of spoilers ahead
after returning from their various
missions the different past moments from
the history of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
The Avengers grouped back up with the
six Infinity stones in tow but Black
Widow was missing as she sacrificed
herself to retrieve the soul stone it
all goes down in a scene that mirrored
the death of Gamora and Avengers
infinity war the new and improved
Professor Hulk who has a combined might
of the Hulk with the intellect of Bruce
Banner use of recreated Infinity
Gauntlet to reverse silos to snap
bringing back all the people who are
erased from existence and Avengers
infinity war but though he tried he
couldn't return Natasha to life it may
seem weird that a guy with an
all-powerful wishing glove still
couldn't undo this one may to death the
black widows absence at the end of the
film proves that the Infinity stones
aren't quite as infinite as that name
would suggest of course that doesn't
mean I heroes can't find the way to
pluck her out of the past and sender OKC
is where things get weird on that trip
back to 2014 to get the power stone is
seen in the beginning of guardians of
the galaxy our timelines nebula was
captured by Thanos who secretly replaced
Sir with the evil 2014 version of nebula
having infiltrated the avengers
headquarters evil nebula then summoned
2014 Thanos and his armies using the
time machine
they blew everything up with evil nebula
getting a hold of the new Infinity
Gauntlet and a callback to the original
comics but then the good nebula from the
real timeline shot a younger evil self
stone-dead luckily this didn't affect
the good nebula at all so what does that
mean it proves our heroes past can't be
changed and that alternate universes are
probably something the MCU is going to
need to sort out and face for with the
Infinity Gauntlet once again in play The
Avengers for Thanos to a standstill
including an absolutely epic sequence
where Captain America gained the powers
of Thor by wielding the mystic hammer
Mjolnir to deliver a massive whopping
something which was first teased way
back in Avengers age of Ultron still
Thanos eventually called in the cavalry
by which we mean the intergalactic horde
of creeps we saw back in Avengers and
luckily the Hulk's reverse snap had also
restored all the dusted heroes from
Avengers infinity war just as Captain
America was about to face the armies of
Thanos alone again echoing a classic
moment from the comics all the dead
heroes arrived via dr. Strange's magic
portals in a scene reminiscent of the
end of ready player one only better plus
the arrival of all the heroes allowed
Captain America to finally deliver the
team's signature catchphrase from the
comics Avengers Assemble something fans
have been waiting for for the last
decade especially after Marvel did a
freakout tease at the end of age of
Ultron
vengers in the end you knew how to come
down to tony stark versus a nose for the
fate of the universe after all the
showdown have been teased way back in
Avengers age of Ultron and luckily Tony
was clued into his big chance because
Doctor Strange was there to give him the
finger no not that finger just an index
finger to note that this was the one
chance in 14 million for victory that he
had foreseen in Avengers infinity war
Stark didn't disappoint
taking the Infinity stones from Thanos
and using it to snap the big purple
meanie out of existence along with all
his minions we learned in guardians of
the galaxy that mere mortals cannot
harness the power of the Infinity stones
though fulfilling that cosmic promise
the strain was too much for Tony he died
a hero and was given a hero's funeral
attended by everyone who was anyone
including Nick Fury and even that kid
from Iron Man 3 as for why it had to be
Tony who saved the day and bit the dust
wellhe's ago started the whole MCU back
with the first Iron Man movie he's been
the heart and soul of the franchise and
without Tony making the ultimate
sacrifice to save the universe it just
wouldn't feel right he may be gone but
he'll never be forgotten I am Iron Man
following Tony's funeral Captain America
was tasked with returning the Infinity
stones to their proper places and time
in order to ensure that no more
alternate universes were created but in
a big twist cap decided not to come back
from his time travel jaunt instead he
returned to the 1940s so he could
finally have that dance he promised
Peggy Carter back in Captain America the
First Avenger and then he stayed there
apparently marrying her and living a
long and full life you're gonna need a
rain check on that day
a week next Saturday at the Stork Club
so Steve Rogers at least got a happy
ending and so that his buddy Sam Wilson
aka the Falcon not only was he brought
back to life but an old Steve Rogers
still spry at well over 100 turns up to
present Sam with this indestructible
shield and the charge to carry on as the
new Captain America a development that
also took place in the comics several
years ago Tony and Steve might be gone
but one of the big three may apparently
still be moving forward in the MCU after
wallowing in self-pity throughout the
whole film Thor finally seemed to get
his act together at the very end and
decided to head into space with the
guardians of the galaxy leaving Valkyrie
behind us a new leader of the US
Guardians we also got a hint of what we
might see when Thor aeneas guardians of
the galaxy returning guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 as their final scene showed
Peter quill searching for the location
of the 2014 version of Gamora who came
through the portal with Panos but
vanished after the final battle but
that's just one of several loose ends
Marvel will have to tie up in a future
movies we won't have to wait long to see
the fallout from avengers endgame as the
teasers despite a man far from home
suggests Peter Parker and happy Hogan
will be dealing in very different ways
with a loss of Tony Stark they aren't
the only ones with things to work
through though after stealing the
tesseract again
Loki got a second chance at life that
seems likely to be explored in the
upcoming Loki series on Disney's new
streaming service Disney Plus likewise
Hawkeye has his family back which is
likely to be explored in the upcoming
Hawkeye series on the same service
meanwhile Wakanda suddenly has us King
back again that's probably one King too
many though because whoever's been
running the show for the last five years
into Charlie's absence mbaku maybe why
not one to just hand the throne back
over and then there's Black Widow who
has a solo film in development even
though she's dead or the heroes rebuild
a time machine to bring her back or the
film be a prequel where we find out she
was a life model decoy this whole time
so many possibilities all told The
Avengers saved a lot of lives and won
the day but that was easy / picking up
the pieces is likely to be the hard part
and we can't wait for phase 4 to begin
so we can see just how they do it check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite Marvel movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and set
the
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]